it is a different i think perspective in
security where like you know most
solutions are very siloed and focused on
one problem we're like you know we're
we're trying to cover it uh you know
kind of fit on the broader like you know
the vertical um at the horizontal not
the verticals and and bringing everybody
in you know i will integrate with
everybody everything a customer has so
they really have to you know eventually
have that this single pane of glass off
these are the issues these are the cause
of the issues and this is how we reduce
risk together so that that's the vision
we're not gonna become a detection tool
um you know as long as you know we we
don't see a need for that you know these
tools are out there we just need to
integrate with them and help solve these
problems
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap
google for startups and hippo and in
media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this one is
about cyber security leadership with
mehrav bahat the ceo and co-founder of
daz who has spent her career creating
category-leading technology products and
building high impact teams
previously mehlav served as general
manager for the cloud security global
business at microsoft and was also
deputy ceo of microsoft israel r d
overseeing more than 2 500 employees
prior she was product strategy group
director for microsoft's cloud and ai
security business unit and chief of
products and business development of
flash networks
has a bachelor's of science in
industrial management engineering from
the technion and a master of business
administration from ben gurion
university and served as a fellow in the
harvard business school kennedy school
of government program
as one of only a handful of female ceo
founders in cyber security mehrab is
focused on mentoring and empowering
women and young leaders
[Music]
you're such an inspiring figure um in in
the ecosystem you know is um today is
the co-founder and ceo of daz looking at
cloud vulnerabilities but a pioneer a
female executive pioneer in the cyber
space it's not a secret that it's not
not at all leaders are our
female leaders there's we're not yet at
a position where we have sort of this
equality and and that especially in the
executive field and and it's something
that i would love to to hear a little
bit about your your own experience and i
know that you're also excited about
mentoring and working with other female
leaders and
and and so beyond that your work is just
fascinating working in a variety of
companies as either as an advisor or as
an executive within microsoft israel and
both in general manager domain but also
in the cloud domain and then
transitioning again to to
entrepreneurship with daz so a lot to
uncover me rav but really the bottom
line question is why do you do what you
do and so might have tell me a little
bit about yourself and how you see
you know what your passions are and what
you're excited about
yeah so um i think you know i'm very
excited about what i do today like you
know it's like tons of energy uh you
know we started the company about a year
and a half ago and since then i think
every day was more exciting than the
other
uh building and growing a company from
from zero that was my passion that was
my dream
i actually didn't think it's possible
for women to do that i don't know why in
my mind but when i started to do that
and i got the best found you know
co-founders since then it was just an
amazing experience yes so i'm motivated
day by day but what we do
now you're you're started out with also
the technion and a certain engineer by
trade
sort of is this you know did you
anticipate this as a as a career
trajectory that you're going to be an
executive in technology roles and then
starting your company or mentioning a
little bit about the the female aspect
but was this always sort of the grand
plan for me love
yeah i know so when i when i was a kid i
actually grew like in paris very of
israel so i didn't really have like you
know any role models any women
founders ceos anything like that so to
me like you know every i think every
step i dream for you know of the next
step like it wasn't like you know 20
years ago i was exactly you know i knew
what i was going to do
so that was a journey and i think that
that's what i love in life just you know
follow your passion
and dream your dreams and dream bigger
and and try to execute them all um yeah
so i think i i decided or i started to
think about starting my own company um
actually when i was vp products at you
know different companies networks and um
i went here to harvard you know for some
more school i came back i went to
microsoft i didn't start my own company
but since then it was like and you know
they come back like i really wanted to
do that and found my you know man the
right to the right team and and to go
execute my dream
so
take me back to to sort of your own
your own beginning of understanding that
that what you want to do is start a
company you're mentioning that it was
back when you were a vice president and
another company and
what is sort of the trigger for you
to to go on this journey for yourself
from ilove
yeah so i think you know i was like you
know um vp products in a company um
and you know like you know i felt you
know very connected to what i did
um but i was like you know if i've done
it from the beginning i would have done
it differently so i always had a
passion to actually start from fresh
and get to my own team you know build a
culture there's a lot about the culture
about the people you work with
the problem you want to solve and then
then execution so i i just thought that
you know starting where starting from
the from the beginning you know i would
do things differently and again a lot
about the culture um so i think you know
that was a great opportunity you know to
start a company and recruit the team
that you really you know you feel that
they're going to be your your partners
for the journey and now we're 55 people
and i you know i was
i was actually interviewing each and
every one of them and and i think that
uh really important to get you know the
culture fit and to have the best people
there and i i feel continue doing it as
as long as i can
um and it's about the team like if you
have the right team the passion
uh to to solve a big problem um the
changing you know you know for us is
exchanging the world of security um and
then together it's it's an amazing
journey so that's what it takes
so take me back a little bit to to
yourself my love and if you're thinking
through
you know what is really important for
you right now in life in the world in
your own vision you know what what are
sort of the opportunities that you're
creating around you you know what what
does it come down to because you're
dealing with fir you're dealing with
fascinating technological feats right
and and definitely it's going to make a
tremendous impact on a variety of
organizations where does this all come
from uh for you meirov
so i think you know i felt that the
problem you know i've been doing
security for
microsoft for four and a half years um
you know being part of the team
that build the
the cloud security stack from from zero
you know from zero you know to like 2.5
billion now then 10 billion of dollars
uh which which is which is huge in so
such a such a short time incredible
yeah what i felt is like you know
security is kind of really focused on
detections and alerting and showing you
what's wrong gives you a lot of
visibility but then we i said you know
and you know talking to our customers
they were frustrated about the fact that
insecurity score is never good and
they're never really able to reduce the
risk and when you talk about cloud and
cloud is so easy you know um you know to
um
you know like you know
any any attacks on the cloud it could
could happen very fast it's very easy to
do that you know you could look for
shell everybody can yeah you know
could utilize and use this uh
vulnerability to uh you know to take
your data um so i think that you know
helping our customers really reduce the
risk and solve these problems
remediating uh those issues and and you
know
is is one of the most important things
in security cannot secure without really
taking it all the way to fixing those
issues that are you know up you know
that's growing and growing you know this
backlog of issues these
you know alerts that are off the charts
nobody take care of them um this is
something they really really need to
focus on and i think that security needs
to you know security products need to
take the next level off let's help
reduce the risk not just show the risk
i love it tell me a little bit about daz
and the the sort of the the vision for
daz you know furious down the line cloud
vulnerabilities how does this play into
our ecosystem of of either security
products or or more importantly the
application of this in in the real world
that we're living in and we're seeing
evolve every day
so i think i mean i think we have like
you know two things that are really
important to us one as i said before is
reducing the risk um and uh the second
thing is really focused on you know
permediation is uh by large it's it's an
organization i think it's like a um you
know it's even like you know um a
collaboration problem you know it's a
problem of the security teams but also a
problem of the engineering we're
creating most of these issues and are
also in charge of fixing them uh so the
way we look at things is trying to first
you know be you know kind of bridge this
gap between those teams and and make
sure that you know security find it's
easier to address those issues
understand root causes not just you know
take a lot of issues a lot of alerts and
throw them over the over the fence to
their developers and from the
engineering side to make it easier for
them to care you know they care about
security rights but to make it easy for
them to you know to create more secure
products uh so to us it's more than just
a product it's actually like you know a
collaboration uh platform between
security and engineering and makes
security easy for everybody so that's
one thing second thing is uh when we
look at cloud security cloud remedy you
know cloud vulnerabilities and also the
the pipeline everything you know to us
you know everything starts in the
pipeline everything starts in code like
everything's you know the cloud is going
to be all you know all applications are
and all infrastructure is you know going
to be coded at some point um so because
code is kind of reusable like you know
people using the same image you know
container in in many applications right
and they're using the same line of code
and terraforming you know to um to speed
up a lot of you know vms and and
what have you so um and and you know the
code repos that are actually you know
kind of you know everybody is not really
writing code is kind of fat um kind of
fat taking you know open source and and
libraries and all that so eventually
it's like a spaghetti of a lot of things
right
yes oh like it's not it's like just
think about you know think of a river
that is eventually gonna you know all
the water goes to the ocean
so you cannot just focus on production
you definitely need to look at the
entire thing and we don't have
separation we collector learns from you
know blessed and right and production
pre-production
and the ability to kind of look at it as
you know the remediation cloud you know
put everything up there do the
correlation the duplication of issues
and be able to figure out which causes
and help security and engineers focus on
their high priorities issues and help
them do it
quickly so these are the two things is
you know bridging the gaps between the
teams and also understanding that
everything is becoming code and that we
need to not separate production
reproduction and just look at it as a
whole
incredible and and how are you
positioning daz into this ecosystem
because there's a lot of different
strategies to go about this you could be
creating a brand that is going to be
working with every company it could be a
technology first organization that has
different channels that are that are
business-wise interesting but it's less
of a brand base because when i look at
daz i look at a very very strong brand
and so i'm i'm interested to hear how
you're thinking about the positioning of
this company long term
with in in a world that you know well
while we you know there's a lot of
different players here the world is
shifting to code first on everything and
and i completely love your analogies to
the spaghetti in the river that was
awesome
thank you
so um so we're really ecosystem friendly
uh we're um i think one of our strengths
is the visibility the entire pipeline
culture production again you know it's
not just the pipeline pre-productions
everything um and our ability to kind of
map every resource in production to the
code that generated it and then we kind
of integrate with all of the tooling out
there it could be like you know um cloud
native solutions it could be uh abstract
solutions could be
you know cloud cspm zwps all the
upcoming
players and also you know some some of
the older um you know stuff out there
and really connects to all of that and
being able to correlate this data coming
from all of them
into actionable uh you know problems
that are solvable and actual items so
obviously we're integrating with
everybody we're really ecosystem
friendly we even have some partnerships
that are um you know even like a go to
market based um so it is a different i
think perspective and security where
like you know most solutions are very
siloed and focused on one problem we're
like you know we're we're trying to
cover it uh you know kind of on the
border like you know the vertical um and
the horizontal not the verticals and and
bringing everybody in you know i will
integrate with everybody everything a
customer has so they really have to you
know eventually have that this single
pane of glass off these are the issues
these are the cause of the issues and
this is how we reduce risk together so
that's that's the vision we're not gonna
become a detection tool um you know as
long as you know we we don't see a need
for that you know these tools are out
there we just need to integrate with
them and help solve these problems
interesting
so first of all best of luck with daz
you know from
anybody taking a look on why you're
doing anything it looks so so great and
and it's um having such a stellar team
i think is remarkable not just your team
but also the people that are that are
backing daz which is a little bit from
the world that i'm coming from those are
some of the the greatest thinkers in the
cyber security space in the world and so
obviously you're you're positioned in a
great place
i'm curious a little bit about your own
personal
you know
vision because you're
you're you're you're also a figure right
i mean and it's a it's something that we
that needs to be understood that the way
that you're leading this company your
own actions your own leadership style
it's reflecting on on a lot of different
people around the world and and i think
you're also open yourself to the idea
that you know also other female leaders
may look at you for inspiration
naturally just because there aren't too
many examples still today which is very
unfortunate how do you think how how
cognizant are you of this is is this
even something that you're thinking
about as you are
leading or is this something that you're
saying yes i know but i'm not really
i don't need to be concerned with that
myself
yeah so
i think you know first i really
would love to see more female leaders
most female co-founders and founders and
ceos and you know of startups and bigger
companies i think it does start with the
startup if you grow the startup you
become a ceo of a bigger company uh
that's the that's enough of the game for
israeli companies i mean i've been an
executive in a bigger like you know
multinational like you know microsoft
but i think there's from my
you know like being in israel and it's
like it's such a like a startup
ecosystem
that's that's the way you should start
you know that's the way we should you
should have warming women attract work
more women so for me when i look at it
it was really important that you know at
the core team of the engineering i will
have a woman and now she's a team leader
and think it's attracts more women to
follow you know to follow the team and
um you know we're not compromising
talent we get the best talent but the
best uh talent that really really and
you know again you know provides um tons
of credibility and i think um you know
good example for other women to follow
these is the star that you know if
you're if you're joining an early stage
startup you you next day you can start
your own company so this is where we
need to start you know at the earlier
stages
um second is you know to me like you
know when i started the company there
weren't um any examples of you know
everybody said that women usually you
know the rounds are smaller than
compared to a man uh so when i did the a
round i think it was the second largest
um other people should look at your
series a round yeah yeah so like it to
me is like okay so women can definitely
get a nice a round uh so we
we've checked that so i think yeah i do
think a little bit about it you know
that you know i want to be a good
example
like
it's it creates some more stress i would
say but i think it's also you know to me
like if i if i make it you know um you
know to become like a big company a
strong company like a you know a strong
example and other other female leaders
will you suppress that and even bigger
larger whatever i would feel you know
honored you know to to be one of those
incredible well it sounds like the
journey starts off very authentically
from your own experience
and both both on the engineering front
but then also on on the executive front
and having been you know becoming a
thought leader in this in the space and
bringing on the right co-founders that
complement you partnering with some of
the great partners that you have and
what i really love seeing is how strong
the brand that you're building is um i
think it reminds me of some of the other
great examples of of companies that
became very very large and understood
that it's not enough to just build a
great technology and especially in the
cyberspace you know if you want to be
differentiated and you want to build a
long-lasting company and the brand and
the trust that you're creating is just a
significant piece of it and obviously
tying back at the end to your the
conversation about female leadership
which which is definitely not the core
of what you're of what you're doing but
i think it's it's it is important
because at the end you know we it's it's
it's a mind-boggling question of it's
2022. why aren't we why don't we have
more female leaders starting cyber
companies um you know when i had my team
in the army um you know we had half of
my team was female engineers and
honestly they were much better than all
of us were so i'm not it's not you know
it's it it mind-boggling for me that
still in 2022 we're we're talking about
this topic but but it was interesting to
hear your perspective and your own
commitment so hey mayrav thank you very
very much i appreciate your time have a
safe flight to boston thank you for
taking the time to do this and best of
luck with daz
thank you and i really wish to you know
you have the chance to interview with
more women uh you know in the future and
thank you so much for the time i think
it was a pleasure thank you
thank you
you